salut salut
[Musique]
Oui, je te souris toujours
Le même
moi qu'est-ce que tu es
salut frère
a agressé ma mère quand elle avait 13 ans
Salut
pourquoi ai-je entré Jono ce que je veux
si près il y a des signes 1
Salut
Venez un, souriez
vivant mais
nous ne connaissons que la formule d'Askes
il y a des années a commencé à être déplacé
quand ceux avec les sourds se sont avérés
ils ne connaissent pas la religion ne savent pas
Allah Subhana la religion du passé est appelée de
voilà enfin mes infos pour Taklim chez
à la maison et enfin libéré
puis peut faire un motif personnalisé pour
ils
je
[Musique]
nous ne l'avons pas plus tard de toute façon nous
qui sont de leurs régions respectives
peut revenir après avoir réussi le déploiement
la religion a remis l'éducation hop
le Coran et fournir une compréhension
à eux que la lecture du Coran
facile d'apprendre cette religion
salut salut
salut salut ça suffit
[Musique]
salut salut